CHARLES NESSON: People aren't organized.
People don't have a way of learning about citizenship.
If you take the core of this ideal, to be the citizen-- we the people--
and you think in legal terms of, how do we legally express our citizenship,
we have very little means, in a way.
We vote, it's true.
But our vote is just one drop in an ocean.
We don't really feel a sense of control through our individual votes.
But jury-- now, jury is something different.
It's not something that we're doing all the time.
But when we are called upon to serve on a jury,
then we are doing something serious-- and actually, the only job
that the Constitution defines for a citizen.
All the rest that is talked about citizenship
is what the state says should be expected of you, as a citizen.
You are to serve the state.
But no, no-- you turn around from the point of view of we
the people, trying to frame a state in which we maintain some hold-- the jury,
that's our opportunity to participate.
So for me, the empowered citizen is the place where
the Declaration of Independence starts.
It's expressed in the jury, in our Constitution.
And we have all we need, even now, to make it work.